today we're talking about how tiny
tina's wonderlands is sparking new hope
that crossplay will finally come to
borderlands 3 on playstation
the upcoming borderlands spin-off tiny
tina's wonderlands will have cross-play
support for all platforms at launch in a
tweet gearbox's randy pitchford thanked
the engineers at gearbox software for
handling the technical considerations of
getting the job done and extended his
gratitude to 2k games microsoft and sony
for coming to terms politically speaking
to allow cross play in another tweet
pitchford asked fans to be patient and
understanding because there might be
technical issues with how crossplay is
implemented in wonderland randy said
quote please take it easy on us if there
are hiccups this is hard stuff and none
of the platforms were designed for this
we've done impossible work to make it
happen and try to make it as easy to use
as possible but this is new territory
and the wild is not a test environment
pitchford's tweet doesn't get into
specifics about how cross play will work
in the game but those details should
come soon given the game launches on
march 25th for xbox one series x and s
ps4 and 5 and pc twice in his tweet
pitchford signaled out sony slash
playstation suggesting the company was
not originally on board with the idea
and that's not surprising considering
sony apparently blocked cross play in
borderlands 3. however cross-play
support for all platforms in borderlands
3 might be coming soon as pitchfirst
says he sees that as being inevitable
now that crossplay is coming to tiny
tina's wonderland borderlands 3
currently supports cross play between
xbox and pc but if you want to play with
your playstation buddies you're out of
luck in other playstation news sony has
announced a new state of play live
stream that will focus on hogwarts
legacy the live stream is scheduled for
thursday march 17th at 2 p.m pacific 5
pm eastern the whole thing will run for
about 20 minutes and will feature over
14 minutes of hogwarts legacy gameplay
captured on ps5 after the gameplay has
been shown off the stream will conclude
with some insight from a few members of
the team at avalanche software set in
the same school made famous by the harry
potter books and films the game is an
open world experience and will see you
take control of your very own witch or
wizard after they enroll in the magical
academy during the 1800s the development
of hogwarts legacy has been a rocky road
so far though as harry potter creator
and author jk rowling has been embraed
in controversy surrounding comments that
have been viewed as transphobic after
some delay speculation it was announced
that the game was still on track for a
2022 release and rowling has no
involvement with the project however
it's important to note that rowling will
still receive a cut of the profits from
hogwarts legacy sales as she receives
royalties from the wizarding world ip in
its entirety switching gears to halo a
new patch is out now for halo infinite
that makes some small but important
changes for the pc edition of the sci-fi
shooter the march 14th update for halo
infinite specifically improved stability
in the pc version by resolving a common
crash the patch notes don't mention the
specifics of the crash scenario though
outside of that fix the update allows
players to start land services from an
in-game menu this patch is very small
weighing in at about 600 megabytes or
less and players will need to close and
relaunch halo infinite to install it and
before we close out shout out to the
accessibility awards for not only
celebrating games that made huge strides
in accessibility but for also getting
detective pikachu to present an award
what a talented guy i mean why why was
that his only movie in his career i mean
he never got cast for anything else and
it's
it's a crime he would make a great
deadpool